ROSALIND STANWELL-SMITH:
Well, my background,
I'm a medical epidemiologist.
I started off in surgery.
But I felt the call of epidemiology.
And during the '90s, I had to run a
course teaching people epidemiology.
And we went down to the John
Snow pub, just to give them
a kind of interesting thing.
And we found that the
pub was really run-down
and no one was bothering about it.
And we knew there was this
big heritage in the states
so we were really
embarrassed, especially
because we had two guys from the CDC
who were lecturing on our course.
As so we said, well, we must
have a John Snow society.
And that's how it started.
DON GOLDMANN: The Institute for
Healthcare Improvement, or IHI,
was founded by Don Berwick, who
you may remember ran for governor.
He's kind of the guru of improvement.
And our mission is to improve health
and healthcare around the world.
And to make care safer and better for
patients and for just general people
who happen to live in a community.
And we do this with a bedrock of
scientific, quality improvement.
And most people think
quality improvement--
you just go out and kind of do it.
But as we've been discussing, it
all involves the scientific method,
you know, prediction, testing,
confirming, adjusting, constantly
running cycles, to prove or disprove
that your theory of causation, how
you get from a change to
a better outcome, is true.
ROSALIND: In a way, the
Miasma Theory was right,
in that there are lots of factors,
your general health, your wellbeing.
They even brought in your morality.
I'm afraid, you know, if you were
immoral, you were going to get cholera.
But that whole idea, the holistic
approach, isn't wrong as such.
But they missed out the single cause.
And people have often said, well, how
was Snow absolutely strong on this?
Well even William Budd,
who was a contemporary,
he came up with the Theory
of Water-borne Typhoid.
He also hedged his bets.
But Snow didn't.
And I think it's very much
because he was a very logical man.
But also, you look at his life.
He starts off as a young doctor in the
minefields of the north of England.
And the mines, in those
days, were disgusting.
You'd go down underground,
there was no sanitation.
If it rained, they'd flood.
They had no way to wash their hands.
They had no toilets.
And he observed this,
and commented on it.
And in 1849 he said, there
must be something going on.
So he was very close to the Germ Theory.
Although he never-- he was years
ahead before people like Robert Koch
came up with the Germ Theory.
But he was close.
And so he was saying, it's
something, it's something
to do with them not washing the hands
and ingesting it from the water.
DON: Well, first I think it's only fair
to say there's no William Farr society.
And you may wonder why
I would bring that up.
Well, it's because
William Farr was wrong.
But he did use statistics, and
one might say epidemiology,
to come to the wrong conclusion.
What he did, as you may know, is to
calculate the occurrence of cholera
around London, and
especially around the Thames,
by the elevation of the
land above the Thames.
And he showed a really strong
correlation between elevation
and lower risk of getting cholera.
Because he believed that
miasmas, these noxious gases that
come from human feces and animal
waste and all that kind of stuff,
all these bad gases
were causing cholera.
And, unfortunately, his
analysis didn't account
for all the other factors that
might have been important,
income level, what kind of house you
lived, what kind of water you got.
All he did was have this theory
about miasmas from the Thames.
And it looks really good.
If you look at that graph, and his data,
it's pretty compelling, but it's wrong.
ROSALIND: There's been
a lot of criticism,
in a way, of the way John Snow
and some of the others of his time
have become an icon of epidemiology.
And people have said, well, why him?
I mean he wasn't the
only one doing maps,
he wasn't the only one who was
beginning to look at statistics.
But what was very interesting about John
Snow, I think, the deductive reasoning.
The fact that he was, yes
he was a qualified doctor,
but he was very much a
scientist of a doctor.
And he believed in measurement.
And he was against
the flow of the times.
There were other people who thought
that cholera might be waterborne.
But it was only as part
of a general theory.
People sometimes want to know
when did epidemiology start.
I mean, we didn't really
call it epidemiology
until well later in the century.
It's really a 20th century
phenomenon, as such.
They wouldn't have thought
of it like that at all.
They understood epidemics because
they had the word in French.
Épidémie.
But it could be just one or
two cases, maybe even one case
if it was a nasty disease.
But the idea of researching
those epidemics,
they would of called like a study.
Or Snow often referred
to the great experiment
that needed to be done to
show that water was the cause.
DON: So when this vast outbreak of
hundreds of cases you said occurred,
he used basic epidemiology, and we use
the term, "shoe-leather epidemiology"
to describe what he did.
He got on his feet and walked around.
And started asking, where are
these illnesses occurring?
And he began to plot
them out on a map, which
is sometimes called the ghost
map, or John Snow's map,
so he could see patterns.
Epidemiologist essentially
look for patterns of disease,
and then make a prediction, or find an
association between hypothetical causes
or origins of the outbreak.
ALYSSA: When you read very
short accounts of this map,
or when you see it presented in
other documentaries, or whatever,
you often get the impression that
John Snow is walking around Soho
with a clipboard and this
map, and putting dots
and making this histogram as he
walks around, which is not true.
And in fact, the more
scholarly accounts that I've
read make it sound like he made the
whole map after, like well after,
this was over.
ROSALIND: Yes, that's right.
ALYSSA: So, did he have a map
he was making in his head?
Did he have a sketch?
Did he just use tables and have a
picture in his head, or what did he do?
ROSALIND: He was very
good at drawing up tables.
And there was something-- because
of his work with anesthesia,
he was very good at
working with compounds
and drawing out effects and things.
So he would have been
making lists of the deaths.
And he would have some people like
the local doctors and Henry Whitehead,
the curator, collecting the death data.
What's very interesting
is his notebooks,
which he kept almost
every day of his life,
for the period that
he's investigating this,
is the time that he doesn't make--
he doesn't keep his notebook--
ALYSSA: He's too busy to write it down.
He's too busy.
And what I think he was
doing was not using a map,
but he was collecting
addresses, and so on.
And when he was presenting the
information to the board of inquiry--
They set up an inquiry, immediately.
So this was a very nasty outbreak with
some important people who had died,
in addition to the poor.
And so he was presenting
the information,
and that's when he drew
the map to convince them.
ALYSSA: The map that's on this
lovely John Snow Society mug.
ROSALIND: Yes.
So he had, if you like,
he'd got the data.
And this was just another
way of demonstrating it.
It wasn't how he solved the outbreak.
DON: When I talk to my students
about this, I always ask them,
so did John Snow perform
a case control study,
which is fundamental in epidemiology.
It's the greatest tool for
working up outbreaks that we have.
In a case control study, you
study the exposure of the cases,
in this case, water
pumps, and the exposure
of the controls, the people who
were not cases, who were not sick,
and their exposure to water pumps.
And there should be a difference.
John Snow did not look at controls.
He only looked at cases.
People were sick, and
arrayed them on a map,
and said these are closer to
the Broad Street water pump,
and here are some exceptions
to prove the rule.
So as the Father of Epidemiology,
the fundamental tool
for working up outbreaks was
not what he actually utilized.
ALYSSA: And the rest of
London not getting sick
is not considered a control?
DON: Well, he didn't really
talk about it that way.
And if you read his stuff, it
wasn't-- he wasn't looking--
he had a vague idea that there
were these people who weren't sick,
but it wasn't in a disciplined way.
Reverend Whitehead, who's not known
as the Father of Epidemiology,
he was a local guy and
he knew everybody and so
he was able to go around
and ask questions.
First he found more cases.
But he also interviewed non-cases.
And that was more like
a case control study.
So maybe Reverend Whitehead ought
to be the Father of Epidemiology.
I mean, but John Snow, what he
did was really quite remarkable.
ALYSSA: So it's at a
particular moment in time
before microscopy is fully
evolving as a proper science,
before the hygiene methods
have really got going.
And yet Snow is 40
years ahead of his time.
In a way, it's tragic he
didn't live to see that.
And what would he have contributed?
Masses, I think.
DON: Isn't it interesting
that you're talking
about how theories, some based
on empiric observation, some
of them remarkably astute, coexisted
side-by-side with nonsense.
ALYSSA: Yes.
DON: And it's no different--
ALYSSA: It's still true
DON: --today.
ALYSSA: Yes.
DON: Right?
I mean, theories-- and I'm not going
to take sides-- but creationism,
homeopathic remedies,
I mean, these are wild,
to me, wild theories that exist
right alongside of modern medicine
with synthetic drugs that are
targeted to conformations of proteins,
and all this data we have about
evolution, and climate change,
and so forth.
So I think it's a natural-- we
hold on to the kind of mysterious,
the not easily explained,
phenomenon and theories.
And at the same time, people
will say, well, you know,
there's this thing called science,
and we can actually use it to predict.